(On vous raconte parfois des sornettes sur votre santé...
(Entre ces foutaises,
ces balivernes,
ces calembredaines et ces billevesées
un homme s'est dressé...
Il est de retour
et il est seul contre tous...
Les médecins le détestent)
Ben non...
(Ta grand mère le déteste !)
Mais non.. M'enfin c'est quoi c't'histoire ?
J'm'entends bien avec les grands-mères et les médecins
(Bon..ok, il s'entend bien avec tout le monde
mais il a des trucs à dire )
Voilà, là d'accord !
(C'est le retour...
du mythobuster !)
On s'était déjà livré à l'exercice il y a quelques temps
on remet ça aujourd'hui
C'est l'heure de démonter quelques mythes
et quelques mythos sur la santé
C'est parti !
C'est par là..
On attrape un rhume à cause du froid, et des courants d'air
Alors, le rhume c'est une maladie hein
C'est une infection des voies respiratoires supérieures
qui est causée par un virus
Et ce virus, il se transmet par la salive
ou les secrétions respiratoires
soit par contact direct
(vous voyez ce que je veux dire, hein...)
soit de façon aéroportée
Non, aéroporté ça veut juste dire
transporté par l'air
(Atchoum...
à vos souhaits)
Transporté par n'importe quel type d'air
pas juste l'air froid, ou des courants d'air
La seule raison pour laquelle il y a plus
de rhumes l'hiver
c'est qu'on reste tous enfermés à l'intérieur
les uns contre les autres
fenêtres fermées
et donc on se refile plus facilement nos germes
C'est tout !
Bon, alors, oui..
quand il fait froid, on a le nez qui coule
c'est vrai
mais c'est juste parce que
la muqueuse est agressée
donc elle sécrète plus de mucus
et qui coule vers l'avant
au lieu de couler vers l'arrière
dans les fosses nasales, comme d'habitude
mais ça coule propre
parce que c'est pas infecté
donc c'est pas une maladie, hein
et d'ailleurs ça s'arrête quand on se met au chaud !
Manger du poisson, ça améliore la mémoire.
Le poisson, c'est plein de phosphore
donc c'est bon pour la mémoire
Vous l'avez déjà entendu celle-la nan?
Alors, est-ce que le poisson contient
beaucoup de phosphore ?
Ben oui, c'est pas faux !
Mais, moins que le fromage
et pas plus que la viande,
ni que le vin !
Dans l'absolu, une bonne vieille raclette
c'est infiniment plus riche en phosphore
que du vieux poisson bouilli tout dégueu
J'aime pas ça le poisson..
Faites comme vous voulez, moi j'aime pas ça
Et le phosphore alors ?
Est-ce que c'est vraiment bon pour la mémoire ?
Parce que apparemment,
y en a plein dans le vin
vous je sais pas,
mais moi les lendemains de soirée ben...
j'me rappelle pas de tout...
Et bah non !
C'est une vieille croyance des années 70
sans réel fondement scientifique
mais mangez du poisson quand même
c'est plein d'oméga 3
J'aime pas ça moi
Ah, et la soupe, ça fait pas grandir
Les poils rasé repoussent plus drus.
Raser les poils,
ça les ferait repousser
plus vite
plus épais
plus forts, plus nombreux
plus cruels
plus....[BIP]
En fait, la seule chose qui change
entre l'épilation et le rasage
c'est que, dans le premier cas, on arrache le bulbe du poil
donc il doit recommencer à pousser de zéro
Du coup,
1 : il met plus de temps à réapparaître à la surface de la peau
donc il pousse pas moins vite
il part juste de plus loin
Et 2 : c'est un poil neuf
avec sa forme de poil qu'on connait bien
Alors que quand on le rase, le poil il est coupé net
parfois même, un peu en biseau
du coup le bout est pointu
et comme en plus il est très court, et donc, pas très souple
ça pique
c'est rèche
mais il est pas plus dru !
Et si les adolescents ont la barbe et les poils des jambes
qui poussent de plus en plus
à partir du moment où ils commencent à les raser
Ben c'est juste parce que c'est le concept de la puberté en fait
les poils poussent de plus en plus
rasage ou pas rasage !
Le gingembre, c'est aphrodisiaque
Bon, alors là, c'est un peu plus compliqué
le gingembre, depuis des siècles
et dans tout un tas de cultures
c'est réputé pour être aphrodisiaque
Mais avant de savoir si ça l'est vraiment...
On va se mettre d'accord sur les termes !
Quand on cherche aphrodisiaque dans le dico
voilà ce qu'on trouve :
"Se dit d'une substance propre à exciter le désir sexuel"
Est-ce que le gingembre excite le désir sexuel ?
Il n'existe aucune étude scientifique
qui démontre que ce soit le cas
pas plus, à priori, que pour n'importe
laquelle des autres substances censées
être aphrodisiaques
D'ailleurs, aphrodisiaque c'est même pas une vraie propriété pharmacologique
donc scientifiquement
c'est non !
Mais bon, le sexe c'est pas de la science
alors si vous aimez bien
le gingembre et que vous avez l'impression
que ça vous fait des guillis dans le bas-ventre
ben vous privez pas
On n'utilise que 10% de notre cerveau
On sait même plus d'où nous vient cette très vieille croyance
mais ce qui est sur, c'est qu'on a très envie d'y croire
Pas vrai Luc ?
C'est fascinant le cerveau hein?
On a bien envie de croire
qu'on est pas complètement à fond encore, hein?
En fait, on sait pas vraiment quel pourcentage de notre cerveau on utilise
mais l'IRM a démontré que toutes les zones du cerveau
étaient actives
juste, elles le sont pas en même temps
D'ailleurs, notre cerveau utiliserait, environ
20% des ressources énergétiques de notre organisme
C'est trop peu pour que tout fonctionne en même temps
de toute façon je sais pas si vous imaginez le bordel
mais c'est quand même beaucoup nan
pour un truc qu'on utiliserait qu'à 10%
Il faut se couvrir quand on a de la fièvre
Quand on a de la fièvre
il faut se couvrir, et bien transpirer hein
On sait pas trop pourquoi
mais on l'a tous entendu
Et bah nan
ça sert à rien et en plus c'est même dangereux
surtout pour les jeunes enfants et pour les personnes âgées
qui risquent de se déshydrater très rapidement
Quand on a de la fièvre, il faut la faire baisser
mais pas trop vite
en plus des médicaments type paracétamol
il faut régler son chauffage à une température
genre autour de 18-19 degrés
et rester habillé de façon normale
et il faut surtout boire beaucoup d'eau
pour compenser les pertes
Pour les enfants,
les pédiatres recommandent
de prendre leur température
et de leur donner un bain de 2 degrés en dessous
pendant une dizaine de minutes
Mais si vous êtes adultes
et que vous aimez les bains
ben vous privez pas !
Voilà DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
si vous avez d'autres mythes et d'autres mythos
à demonter
dites moi ça dans les commentaires
on se retrouve très bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo
D'ici là, mettez vous bien
et surtout, portez vous bien !